Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Heute mit einem kleinen Gespräch mit Giovane Elber über seine Herkunft, über seine Anfänge in Europa und wie er dann zum Markenbotschafter des FC Bayern wurde. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ihr habt richtig gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich habe ein kleines Gespräch mit Giovane Elber führen dürfen. Das hier ist es noch nicht. Das ist noch ein kleiner Prolog. Es ist ein interessantes Gespräch geworden. Hätte man leicht ein Tribünengespräch draus machen können, aber ehrlich gesagt bin ich schon wirklich dankbar, dass dem Rasenfunk 30 Minuten mit Giovane Elber zugestanden werden. Ich hoffe, ihr könnt auch euren Hörgewinn aus diesen 30 Minuten ziehen. Mir hat es auf jeden Fall Spaß gemacht für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt zum ersten Mal mit dem Rasenfunk in Kontakt kommen. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und ich bin Moderator dieser kleinen, aber feinen Fußballsendung. Im Kurzpass sprechen wir in kürzeren Folgen über alles aus der Welt des Fußballs. Da könnt ihr mal reinhören. Es gibt Folgen zum Doping im Fußball, zur Situation Barca nach dem Wechsel von Neymar. Es gibt verschiedene Themen, die euch interessieren könnten. Es gibt außerdem die Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräche, ausführliche Gespräche zu einem einzelnen Thema, zum Beispiel Fußball-Taktik oder auch Rückblick auf die Karriere eines einzelnen Profi-Fußballers. In dem Fall Ralf Gunnisch ist gerade eine sehr gerne gehörte Folge. Und es gibt noch die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz. Darin spreche ich immer mit einem oder mehreren Gästen über den zurückliegenden Bundesligaspieltag. Das alles sei euch herzlich ans Herz gelegt. Und ihr könnt uns auch unterstützen, unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Könnt ihr dabei helfen, dass aus dem Hobby ein Beruf wird und dass wir vielleicht noch viel mehr Gespräche führen können, wie jetzt dieses mit Giovane Elber, das ihr gleich hören werdet. Viel Spaß und los geht's. Giovane Elber, anders als viele andere Ex-Fußball-Profis hatten Sie schon während Ihrer Karriere einen Plan, wie es mal weitergehen soll. Sie haben schon ein Haus gebaut in Brasilien, während Sie noch in Deutschland gespielt haben. Und jetzt sind Sie Inhaber einer sehr großen Rinderfarm. Ich habe irgendwas gelesen von über 6000 Rindern. Wie muss ich mir denn Ihren Tagesablauf jetzt vorstellen?
Also ich habe immer Angst gehabt, nach dem Karriere nichts zu machen. Und ein ex-brasilianischer Nationalspieler hat mir gesagt, du Giovane, du musst irgendwas schon machen oder haben, dass du, wenn du aufhörst, dass du am nächsten Tag früh aufstehen musst, um zu arbeiten. Und so hat ein Onkel von meiner Frau mir ein Farm gezeigt in Brasilien, obwohl ich mit Farm gar nichts am Hut habe. Aber ich habe das angeschaut und gesagt, es ist nicht schlecht. Man ist mit der Natur verbunden, also es ist kein Stress hier draußen, mit dem Tier.
6.000 Tiere sind kein Stress?
Nein, es ist kein Stress. Also die sind in freier Natur, die laufen da ganz frei, die kriegen was zum Essen, das Gras, die kriegen das Wasser. Man muss nur aufpassen, dass genug Wasser da ist ansonsten. Also viel Arbeit ist das nicht. Ich habe nur 13 Mitarbeiter, die das betreiben, und das war sehr schön. Ich glaube, das war das Beste, was ich machen konnte, weil heute ist für mich so, weil ich bin für FC Bayern viel unterwegs. Und dann, wenn ich Zeit habe und wenn ich auf meiner Farm bin, da heißt es, jetzt wird die Batterie aufgeladen. Und das ist sehr schön.
Wie muss ich mir das dann vorstellen? Sie stehen morgens wahrscheinlich sehr früh auf mit den Rindern, setzen sich auf dem Pferd oder in den Jeep und inspizieren dann alles. Also ich kann mir das nicht so ganz vorstellen, vor allem wenn man ja keine Vorerfahrung hat.
Also normal stehen wir so um 5 Uhr morgens auf, dann bis um 6 Uhr frühstücken, ein bisschen im Internet schauen, was los ist. Und dann ab 6 Uhr, weil es noch frisch ist und es ist schon hell. Und dann sitz du auf einem Pferd und gehst auf die Wiese und siehst bei den Trinder, ob die was brauchen, ob alles in Ordnung ist, ob das Wasser da ist oder das Gras in Ordnung ist. Dann kontrollierst du das alles bis um 10 Uhr ungefähr. Dann ist Mittagessen Zeit.
Um 10 Uhr?
Ja, schon um 10 Uhr.
Da wird man um 5 Uhr aufstehen.
Ja, weil dann wird es zu heiß. Ich habe meine Farm in der Mitte Brasiliens, und von 10 Uhr bis 16 Uhr kannst du nicht mit dem Pferd irgendwas machen, weil das ist schon sehr hart. Nach dem Mittagessen schaue ich mit dem Auto oder mit dem Quad noch irgendwas. Und dann ist schon die Zeit um, und dann Abendessen um 18 Uhr, 18.30 Uhr, 19 Uhr, 20 Uhr, schon ins Bett.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich auch, wie man um 5 Uhr aufstehen kann. Das wäre für mich nicht sehr viel Stress gewesen, ehrlich gesagt. Man liest ja immer so, dass Sie jemand sind, der mindestens zwei Heimaten hat, und nicht nur die brasilianische. Sie haben auch mal über sich gesagt, Sie sind ein Brasilianer mit europäischer Mentalität. Deswegen würde ich darüber gerne mal mit Ihnen sprechen, das interessiert mich. Erzählen Sie mir erstmal von Ihrer brasilianischen Heimat. Sie sind in Londrina aufgewachsen, der viertgrößten Stadt Brasiliens, also sehr groß. Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Also das ist so, ich sage immer, Londrina ist noch eine kleine Stadt vor Brasilien. Es lebt eine Hauptmillion Einwohner in Londrina, aber wir haben São Paulo mit 16 Millionen, Rio de Janeiro bei 5 oder 6 Millionen. Deswegen ist Londrina eine kleine Stadt, aber es ist sauberer. Das ist nicht weit weg von São Paulo, 600 Kilometer. Also für uns in Brasilien ist es ein Katzensprung bis nach São Paulo, wo in São Paulo dort geht es um die Arbeit. Rio de Janeiro ist mehr so das Leben genießen, Strand, Karneval, São Paulo arbeiten. Und Süden Brasilien, von Londrina, wo ich wohne, Richtung Süden bis Porto Alegre, dann ist es auch arbeiten. Ganz an der ersten Stelle arbeiten und dann das Leben genießen, kommt zur zweiten, dritten Stelle.
Ok, Sie sind dann ja sehr, sehr früh zum AC Milan gewechselt, nämlich schon mit 18 Jahren. Ich stelle mir den Sprung unheimlich schwierig vor. Sie haben auch mal in einem Interview gesagt, Sie hätten in der Zeit, ich zitiere, Tag und Nacht geweint. Ich hoffe, es war nicht ganz so schlimm. Es war eine kleine Übertreibung. Sie haben damals eine Mannschaft gespielt mit Paolo Mandini, Frank Reikert, Ruth Kulid, Marco van Basten und Trainer Argo Sacchi, also den ganz Großen. Wie war denn diese Zeit für Sie mit 18 Jahren von Brasilien, von der Familie weg und dann gleich bei Sohn im Verein?
Ja, zuerst war es so, 1991 haben wir das Weltpokal in Portugal gespielt, 17, 18 und dann sind wir zweiter geworden, verloren gegen Portugal, dann bin ich nach Brasilien zurückgeflogen mit der Nationalmannschaft. Gelandet, nicht mal 24 Stunden später, ruft mir der Präsident von meinem Ex-Verein, Londrina, an und sagt, wir fliegen morgen schon nach Mailand, weil er Mailand kaufen will. Ich habe gesagt, das ist ein Witz, das kann nicht sein, von Londrina, weil es waren andere Spieler bei der Brasilienischen Nationalmannschaft, die beim großen Verein in Brasilien gespielt haben, schon erste Ligafahrung gehabt haben, wieso jetzt der Giovane Elber aus Londrina jetzt Bayern Mailand spielen soll. Aber das hat es gestimmt, also so ein Glück, und dann sind wir ein, zwei Tage später nach Mailand geflogen und dann hat man getroffen Berlusconi, Ariédo Breida und Spieler dann. Im Trainingsgelände waren alle Spieler. Also für mich war es wie ein Traum, weil am Sonntag haben noch die Spieler gesehen im Fenster und dann auf einmal drei, vier Tage später bin ich da, ich bin mit den Spielern, die ich im Fenster gesehen habe, und sie sagen, das gibt es doch nicht. Nein, das ist nicht wahr. Und das hat alles gestimmt, also wir haben einen Vertrag gemacht, wir haben damals 1 Million US-Dollar, Lundrinas überwiesen, aber es durften nur drei Ausländer spielen, es gab keine EU-Regel und das waren die drei Holländer. Und dann soll ein kleiner Giovane Elber einen Marco Van Basten verdrängen, das geht kaum, weil der war der Top-Torjäger damals in der europäischen Liga. Und so hat AC Milan mir in der Schweiz ausgeliehen. Und das war das Beste, was mir passieren konnte, glaube ich, weil in der Schweiz habe ich gelernt, wie man hart trainieren muss, das Fußball spielen, europäische Fußball spielen, Q-Tour, alles in einer. Es war nicht leicht, die Anfangsphase, also das stimmt schon, dass ich geweint habe, nicht ganz Tag und Nacht, aber meistens Nacht habe ich sehr geweint, weil ich war ganz alleine. Und in einer Welt, wo ich das nicht kannte.
Und es gab ja auch noch kein Internet, man konnte damals ja nicht einfach zu Hause sein.
Genau, alles andere als heute. Heute kann man sich schnell verbinden mit seiner Familie, egal wo die sind, auf der ganzen Welt ist man schnell da. Aber früher gab es nur das Telefon. Und das war nicht einfach, aber später habe ich gesagt, was schwieriger war, es war gut für mich, weil ich ein Mann geworden bin in der Zeit. Weil ich war 18, das erste Mal, dass ich von zu Hause weg war. Und dann auf einmal musst du ein Mann sein. Also du musst einkaufen gehen, du musst Sachen in der Bank machen, musst noch konzentriert sein am Wochenende um Fußball zu spielen. Weil da war kein Spaß mehr, das war schon mein Beruf, sagen wir so. Und ja, ich habe es gut hinbekommen, nach sieben Monaten konnte ich schon ein bisschen Deutsch sprechen, oder Schweizerdeutsch damals. Und dann ist es viel einfacher geworden. Und dann nach dem ersten Jahr, ich wollte gar nicht mehr weg aus Europa oder aus der Schweiz. Also ich wollte schon hier bleiben. Weil in den ersten Monaten, ich habe immer wieder Mama angerufen und gesagt, Mama, ich will zurück nach Hause, ich schaffe das nicht. Also hier spielen die keinen Fußball. Mama, Essen hier. Jetzt habe ich Geld.
Warum spielen die keinen Fußball? Was hat ihnen denn gefehlt?
Weil es war viel zu schnell. Und es war viel zu langsam. Das kann man auch so sehen. Aber es war so, ich habe gesagt, Mama, damals, wenn ich in Brasilien war, ich habe kein Geld, um gutes Essen zu kaufen. Heute habe ich Geld, um Essen zu kaufen, aber ich kann nichts kaufen, weil ich die Sprache nicht kenne. Also was ist das für eine Welt? Also ich will zurück nach Hause, ich will kein Geld mehr. Und dann hat sie gesagt, nein, du sollst da bleiben. Bleib in der Schweiz, spielst eine Saison, und dann sieht man weiter, wie es weitergeht. Aber den ersten Monat musst du bestehen. Du wolltest Fußballer werden. Du bist jetzt geworden. Und du willst jetzt alles hinschmeißen. Da habe ich gesagt, Mama ist hart. Also ich muss doch hier bleiben.
Aber Sie wissen ja, Sie sind ja selber Vater. Manchmal muss man als Eltern auch hart sein.
Das war ganz wichtig, was meine Mama gemacht hat. Also, Gott sei Dank habe ich nicht mit meinem Papa gesprochen. Weil mein Papa hätte gleich sofort gesagt, komm zurück nach Brasilien. Du arbeitest hier, machst einen normalen Job hier in Brasilien. Und fertig, vergiss das mit dem Fußball. Aber Mama war schon hart. Ich glaube, sie hat auch gemerkt, das war für mich die Möglichkeit, meine Familie zu unterstützen. Weil die Familie, wir waren nicht richtig arm, aber wir mussten heute arbeiten, um das Essen von gestern zu bezahlen. Und das war richtig, was die Mama gemacht hat.
Bevor wir zu Zürich, Stuttgart und dann ja auch den FC Bayern kommen, Sie haben noch einen Spieler kennengelernt beim AC Milan, nämlich Carlo Ancelotti, den habe ich weggelassen. Wie haben Sie ihn damals erlebt?
Boah, der war schon ein gestandener Profi beim AC Milan. Mein Eindruck war so, nicht nur von Carlo Ancelotti, sondern auch von Barresi, von Maldini, Donadoni und alles, wie sie heißen, dass ich 1,50 Meter war und die waren 2 Meter, 3 Meter hoch.
Kommt daher auch das El Giovane? Der kleine Elber?
Ja, der kleine Elber, der da trainiert hat, wie das alles war. Beim Essen hat Barresi immer das gesagt, wir haben gegessen, das durfte keiner aufstehen, bis er das Kommando gegeben hat. Selbst Spieler wie Hurtgulli, Van Basten, die mussten alle warten, bis alle gegessen haben. Und dann noch ein bisschen und dann hat Barresi an den Tisch gezeigt, jetzt darf man aufstehen, jetzt können wir aufs Zimmer gehen. Das war für mich Wahnsinn, das ist wie Militär hier, das ist kein Fußballverein. Aber ich habe von denen sehr viel gelernt. In kurzer Zeit, als ich dort war und die Freundschaftsspiele, die ich bei FC Bayern, bei AC Milan gemacht habe, ich habe sehr viel gelernt mit denen.
Und dann eben die Zeit in Zürich, wo sie jetzt gerade schon gesagt haben, da sind sie zum ersten Mal so richtig angekommen. Es war ja auch dann eine erfolgreichere Zeit, auch sportlich, sie durften spielen, sie haben Erfolge feiern können. Wer waren da so die wichtigsten Personen, die ihnen dabei geholfen haben, sich an das Spiel, an die Kultur zu geben?
Also ich habe einen Trainer, Udrich Zwaab gehabt, das war mein erster Trainer beim Grasshoppers und er hat mich schon richtig unterstützt. Er hat immer gesagt, durch die Übersetzer, hat er immer gesagt, was ich machen muss. Ich darf nicht immer nur zu Hause drin sein, weil ich habe immer gedacht, nein, ich bleibe lieber zu Hause, gehe nicht irgendwo, weil ich morgen trainieren muss, ich muss immer konzentriert sein, ich will das Beste geben. Aber da hat der Trainer gemerkt, dass ich immer zum Training gekommen bin und dass ich platt war, weil ich kaputt war, nur von zu Hause zu sein, Computerspiele zu spielen und schlafen zu haben. Ich habe Tag und Nacht geschlafen. Nach dem Training bin ich nach Hause gefahren, abends geschlafen, dann nächsten Morgen trainen, dann wieder abends geschlafen. Also es war schon ein Problem für mich selbst. Und dann hat der Trainer gesagt, nein, du sollst in die Disco gehen.
Das hat der Trainer gesagt.
Der hat gesagt, geh in die Disco, geh in ein Restaurant. Der hat gesagt, Trainer, wie soll ich da bestellen? Ich kann das nicht lesen, was alles drin ist. Deswegen machst du den deutschen Kurs, also mit der Zeit wird das alles kommen. Und dann auch die deutschen Lehrungen, die ich gehabt habe, die waren hervorragend, weil die haben mir dann richtig das Start gezeigt, das Leben, also wir sind zum Automobil-Salon nach Genf und sie hat mir gezeigt, mit dem Zug, wie alles gemacht wird, wie man Tickets kaufen soll, das Leben halt. Nicht nur in vier Wänden, dass man alles lernen muss, sondern das Leben, was ich brauche, täglich hat die mir alles beigebracht.
Ist er eigentlich dann auch das, was man jedem, nicht nur brasilianischen Spieler, sondern einfachen Spieler, der aus einem anderen Land, aus einer anderen Kultur kommt, hier wünschen würde, wenn er in der Bundesliga anfängt, wäre das nicht eine perfekte Rolle für Sie?
Ja, ich sage es um jeden Spieler, der zum FC Bayern kommt, ausländische Spieler oder nicht nur zum Bayern, brasilianische Spieler, die in der Bundesliga sind, versuch schnell die Sprache zu lernen. Und dann wird das Leben ganz einfach. Und dann genießt du auch das Leben hier. Weil zuerst, wenn man kommt, wenn man hier ist und landet, das ist Arbeit. Das heißt, Uhrzeit, von 10 Uhr bis 5 Uhr muss ich beim Verein sein, dann am Tag bin ich zu Hause und dann muss ich das und das alles machen. Aber wenn man die Sprache lernt und dann gehst du in die Stadt, wirst du die Kultur, kannst mit den Menschen hier kommunizieren. Und dann wird es auch für die Familie viel einfacher. Das sage ich jedem, aber klar, jeder macht sein Ding. Es gibt Spieler, die haben Angst, mehr involviert zu werden, weil der Berater kommt und sagt, nein, ich mache das schon für dich. Du bist mein Junge. Und dann der Berater spricht Englisch oder auch ein bisschen Deutsch.
Zu sehr verhätschelt.
Genau, und dann macht er, dass der Junge nicht die Sprache lernt, weil der Berater es viel zu einfach macht. Ich finde das ist nicht schön, weil der Junge selbstständig sein muss. Also es ist gut, wenn man einen guten Berater hat. Aber ein guter Berater darf nicht wie ein Kindermädchen sein. Und heutzutage sind viele so, wie Kindermädchen. Also mein Berater hat mir mal angesprochen, er sagt, Giovane, ich kann für dich die Bank-Sachen machen. Die Sachen, die du zahlen musst, kann ich machen. Ich sag, ich mach das selbst. Ich kann zum Bank gehen. Also ich bin ein normaler Mensch wie alle anderen.
Sie hatten ja auch eine Banklehre, oder?
Ja, das habe ich auch. Deswegen wollte ich alles allein machen, weil ich es nicht geschafft habe. Und dann hat Leute vom Verein gefragt, oder hat mein Berater dann gefragt, wie macht man das? Weil sonst lernt man nicht. Und die sind von vielen Fußballern. Wenn die aufhören mit dem Fußball, wenn ihnen das normaler Leben kommt, die sind richtig aufgeschmissen.
Ja, und andere haben dann eben eine Rinderfarm mit ein paar tausend Rindern.
Ja, wenn man nicht weiß, was man machen kann, und dann kauft man eine Farm und arbeitet mit dem Rinder.
Ich sage Ihnen alleine über das Thema, könnte ich lange mit Ihnen reden. Aber jetzt würde es mich mal interessieren, haben Sie sich dann in Zürich zum ersten Mal richtig heimisch gefühlt, in Europa? Oder kam das dann erst mit dem Wechsel zu Stuttgart und später dann Bayern?
Nein, nein, schon nach der ersten Saison beim Grasshoppers. Weil die erste Spiel bei Grasshoppers, ich bin dann heimgefahren und habe gesagt, nein, das ist nicht der Giovane Elber, der in Brasilien Fußball gespielt hat. Das ist nicht der Giovane Elber, der aus dem Ereignis 1 Mio. USD bezahlt hat. Also mein Eindruck war, ich war nicht da. Obwohl ich auf dem Platz war, habe Schmerzen, Oberraum, ganzer Körper. Aber Fußball, wirklich so Fußball gespielt, habe ich nicht. Ab der siebte, achte Monate, dann hat es angefangen. Dann habe ich auch genossen das Fußballspielen. Weil dann konnte ich mit meinen Mitspielern kommunizieren. Und dann nach einem Jahr, also zwölf Monaten, jetzt bin ich angekommen. Jetzt bin ich ein Schweizer, ein Schweizer-Brasilianer.
Aber das heißt, zum Heimisch fühlen hat immer das Fußballerisch sich angekommen fühlen gehört?
Ja, weil mein Beruf war Fußballer. Ich musste zuerst alles passen im Fußball, damit ich Fuss fassen kann. Weil das Traurigste war, da kommst du in die Kabine, dein Mitspieler lachst dir ins Gesicht aus. Weil du schlecht gespielt hast oder schlecht trainiert hast. Aber keiner wusste, was du in der Nacht da geweint hast. Oder deine Gedanken, dass deine Gedanken nicht 100% da waren. Aber mit solchen Sachen muss man lernen. Und ich glaube, ich habe gelernt, dass ich nach dem ersten Jahr und dann zum dritten Jahr, in der dritten Saison beim Grasshoppers, also ich wollte da nicht weg von GC. Weil es war schön, weil ich schon Freunde hatte, schon Freundinnen hatte, schon ein ganzes Umfeld, wo ich mich bewegen konnte. Und dann habe ich gesagt, pfff, aber jetzt der nächste Schritt. Weil aus dem Mainland habe ich gesagt, nein, also jetzt, in drei Jahren kommst du zurück zu uns. Aber es war noch kein Platz, war ja sehr im Mainland. Und dann kommt das Kontakt zum VfB Stuttgart. Da sag ich, Leute, bitte, lasse ich nach Stuttgart gehen. Weil die deutsche Sprache kann ich schon. Und ich schaue jeden Wochenende die deutsche Bundesliga. Also ich glaube, in der Bundesliga für mich ist das besser. Und dann haben die mir dann zum VfB Stuttgart verkauft.
Und war es dann auch genauso, wie sie es sich erhofft hatten?
Ja, sogar noch besser. Weil ich hatte das Glück, dass in dem gleichen Jahr hat VfB Stuttgart Fredi Bobic gekauft von Stuttgart Kickers. Und das war wie Liebe auf den ersten Blick. Es hat alles gepasst, es hat alles funktioniert. Schon vom ersten Tag, als wir miteinander waren, im Trainingslager, habe ich gesagt, das ist ein Kerl. Also das ist einer, an dem man vertrauen kann. Und ich glaube, der hat auch an mir sowas gemerkt. Und so ist es auch geworden. Dann später, dass VfB Krasimir Balakov gekauft hat. Und dann haben wir das March für Dreiecke, das heute noch viel gesprochen wird über March für Dreiecke. Das war für mich wirklich die beste Zeit, die ich im Fußball gehabt habe.
Sie mussten damals ja auch nicht so viele Defensivaufgaben machen. Ich habe mir ein paar alte Interviews von Ihnen angehört. Jetzt kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es dem Stürmer gut gefallen hat, dieses magische Dreieck. Was hat Ihnen denn an Deutschland selbst, was ist Ihnen da in Erinnerung geblieben? Gab es Dinge, die Sie vielleicht noch überrascht haben, obwohl Sie mit der Schweiz schon ein bisschen näher an die deutsche Kultur gerückt waren?
Also, was mir gefällt hat, war die Mentalität, die deutsche Mentalität. Sie war ganz anders und verschiedener als die brasilianische Mentalität. Aber die Zeit, dass ich in der Schweiz war, ich habe schon etwas gelernt, und dann kommt sie in Deutschland, da sag ich, ja, das ist wirklich so, so sind die Deutschen.
Ist das wirklich so?
Die brauchen Zeit, den Leuten, an Leute zu gehen. Aber wenn die angekommen sind, dann sind sie Freunde. Aber wirklich. Und wer in Brasilien, nein, trifft du einen heute auf der Straße, hey Kumpel, mein Freund, Freund fürs Leben. Das ist schon anders. Und das gefällt mir so. Also es braucht Zeit. Und heutzutage bin ich auch so geworden. Also ich bin nicht wie ein normaler Brasiliener, wo schon zumal ich sage, hey Freund, Kumpel, komm lass uns nach Hause gehen. Nein, es braucht schon ein bisschen Zeit, dass man sich der Andere erkennt.
Mit dem VfB Stuttgart haben Sie ja den DFB-Pokal gewonnen. Und dann gab es den Wechsel zum FC Bayern, der dann den Trophäenschrank ein bisschen aufgefüllt hat. Viermal Deutscher Meister, dreimal DFB-Pokalsieger, Champions League-Sieger, Weltpokalsieger, sogar zum zweiten Mal schon. Mit Milan ja auch schon. Sie haben später in einem Interview mal gesagt, dass man bei Bayern so einen Chip in den Kopf gepflanzt bekommt, der dafür sorgt, dass man selbst nach einem wichtigen Sieg sofort an das nächste Spiel denkt, dass man wieder gewinnen müsse. Und deswegen könne man seine Erfolge gar nicht so richtig genießen. Haben Sie es denn jetzt im Nachhinein wenigstens geschafft, das wertschätzen zu können?
Also jetzt schon, aber das hat geschimpft. Also was ich gesagt habe, kommst du hierher, weil bei uns, mit dem VfB Stuttgart, es war Spaß zu haben im Fußballspielen. Deswegen, wir haben nicht viel gewonnen, nur das Pokal, aber wir haben Spaß im Fußball. Und bei Bayern ist es so, dass kannst du Spaß im Fußball haben, aber das musst du im Spiel gewinnen. Wenn es Spieler gibt, musst du 1-0 gewinnen. Und fertig, basta. Ich habe einmal gesagt, nach einem Spiel, habe ich gesagt, heute war Arbeitssieg. Heute war für mich der schlimmste Tag, weil ich habe Eindruck, ich habe auf dem Fußballplatz gearbeitet. Um heute die drei Punkte zu holen. Das war früher nicht so. Früher hat man die Punkte geholt, weil man Spaß hat am Fußball. Aber ich habe später gesehen, so wird man erfolgreich. Also Spaß ist schön, echt, aber man muss versuchen, auch die schwierigen Spiele mit 1-0 zu gewinnen. Und beim VG Stuttgart haben wir immer versucht, viele Tore zu schießen. Hat er auch geklappt? Ja, aber Bayern und die Spiele haben mehr Tore kassiert, als er geschossen hat. Und vor allem auswärts. Und dann gewinnt man nicht. Also bei FC Bayern, vor allem bei FC Bayern, das habe ich früher nicht gewusst, weil mit VFB Stuttgart war ja nur Meisterschaft, der FP-Pokal. Beim Bayern hast du noch Champions League. Und dann fast das ganze Jahr in der inglischen Woche. Also es kommt schon am Wochenende, wie soll ich heute Fußball spielen? Weil es tut alles weh. Aber das musst du spielen, musst du versuchen, noch das Spiel zu gewinnen. Weil am Ende wird alles ganz knapp. Wer Meister wird, wer nicht, wer Champions League geht, wer nicht geht. Und ich bin froh, dass ich jedes Jahr, als ich beim FC Bayern war, habe ich einen Titel oder sogar zwei Titel gefeiert am Ende des Saisons. Und das konnte man nur dann richtig genießen, wenn man aufhört mit dem Fußball. Und dann kann man zwickeln und sagen, ich bin froh, damals, war schön. Aber an dem Tag, man freut sich, man trinkt ein Bier mehr mit dem Kumpels, man geht irgendwo was essen, aber man geht dann zum Urlaub, nach dem Urlaub kommt man zurück, es fängt wieder bei Null an. Und das ist das Gute an der FC Bayern-Mentalität. Weil man feiert nicht lange, weil der Gegner steht schon in Nacken und die wollen immer uns, gegen uns gewinnen.
Sie sagen, das ist das Gute, wenn man die Titel anschaut, dann hat es sich im Nachhinein auch gelohnt, aber andererseits, wo holt man sich denn dann noch den Spaß? War da dann vielleicht auch München die richtige Stadt für Sie, von der Art und Weise, wie hier gelebt wird?
Ja, dass Familie gut geht und dann auch mit dem Titel, ganz klar. Weil dann wird man immer bekannter und bekannter, weil in Brasilien früher, es kommt nur FC Bayern-Fans, auf einmal ist alle Spiele aus der Bundesliga, da konnte man dann schauen, sogar noch der DFB-Pokal. Und dann sagt man, nein, wir müssen schon jetzt gewinnen, wir müssen Titel gewinnen, weil so wird man auch zu Hause bekannt.
Das heißt, Sie würden schon sagen, München ist zu Ihrer Heimat auch geworden, neben Brasilien?
Ja, das kann man voll sagen. Also klar, ich bin aufgewachsen, in Brasilien geboren, aber die Zeit, dass ich hier in Deutschland gelebt habe und sogar in München sechs Jahre war, das war sehr schön. Heute noch, wenn ich hier mit meiner Familie bin, der Eindruck ist, ich bin gar nicht in Brasilien. Ich bin immer noch in München.
Willi Sanyol hat mal erzählt, ihn hat es hier irritiert in Deutschland, als er die deutschen Altglaskontainer gesehen hat, und die sind nach Farben sortiert. Gab es was Ähnliches bei Ihnen auch, wo Sie sich gedacht haben, in was für einem Land bin ich hier geplant?
Nein, das nicht. Ich finde nur gut, was die machen. Das ist nicht schlecht. Heute in Brasilien, nach 15 Jahren, heute ist Brasilien angekommen. Dieses sortierte Glas, Plastik in richtige Mülleimer. Früher haben wir das schon alles gemacht. Und ich finde das toll.
Aber Sie können doch nicht alles gut finden. Das muss doch auch mal nerven. Das nervt ja sogar mich.
Ach so, das Wetter ein bisschen. Mit dem Winter habe ich schon ein bisschen Probleme. Nach wie vor.
Jetzt haben Sie natürlich was gesagt, wofür die Deutschen dann selber nichts können. Warum sind Sie eigentlich so ein höflicher Mensch? Wer hat Ihnen denn das mitgegeben? Das ist mir nämlich aufgefallen in all Ihren Interviews.
Das kommt von der Familie.
Die Mama wieder.
Mama, Papa, meine Bruder. Als ich angefangen habe, haben sie immer gesagt, du bist der kleine Giovane. Auch wenn du ganz großer Fußballer wirst, aber zu Hause oder in London bist du der kleineste, der jüngste bei uns in der Familie. Du musst immer alle Menschen respektieren. Und das stimmt. Und das hat auch Silvio Berlusconi zu mir gesagt. Ich bin bei Semailand gelandet, und dann kommt Silvio Berlusconi und sagt, vor dem Spieler ist ein Mensch. Der Spieler stirbt irgendwann. Fußball spielen kannst du bis 30, 40. Und dann ist es vorbei. Aber der Mensch, Giovane Elber, wird weiterleben. Lass den Spieler nicht vor dem Menschen stehen. Und das stimmt, das stimmt wirklich. Deswegen bis heute noch gut akzeptiert. Egal, wo ich hingehe, die Leute kommen, wollen ein Foto, ein Autogrammkarten. Das ist schön, muss man schon sagen.
Jetzt sind Sie ja zu so einer Art brasilianischen Botschafter hier in Deutschland geworden. Und wenn man ehrlich ist, hat man als Deutscher in seiner Schulausbildung und auch sonst gar nicht so viele Bezugspunkte zu Brasilien. Tatsächlich ist das häufigste Sport. Und vor allem auch Fußball. Sehen Sie das als Belastung, dass Sie manchmal auch so ein bisschen Botschafter für das komplette brasilianische Volk sind? Oder ist das eher eine Chance für Brasilien, sich in der Welt darzustellen?
Nein, es ist eine Chance. Es ist auch eine Chance, Brasilien zu zeigen, das zu sehen. Und das Schönste ist diese Botschafter-Arbeit, die ich bei FC Bayern habe. Weil ich bin Brasilianer und dann auf einmal ruft der FC Bayern und sagt, Giovane, du sollst in der deutschen Botschaft in Changai, in China sein. Für uns. Ein Brasilianer soll jetzt bei der deutschen Botschaft sein. Aber es war sehr schön. Es hat Spaß gemacht, mit den Leuten zu unterhalten und vor allem über Fußball. Fußball verbindet Menschen. Egal, was für Religion, Hautfarbe, Kultur die haben, Fußball verbindet Menschen. Auch wenn ich schon seit 2006 kein Fußball mehr spiele. Aber es gibt immer einen oder andere, die vor kurzem gesehen haben, auf YouTube und so. Die Tore, die ich geschossen habe. Und man kommt schnell ins Gespräch. Und dann, wenn man anfängt, das merkt man, und dann kann ich nicht aufhören. Und dann kann ich stundenlang hier erzählen, ob das ganze Leben, Welt und Spielen, wie es war, wie die Kabine war. Und Leute freuen sich, um solche Geschichten zu hören.
Sie haben gesagt, Fußball verbindet die Menschen. Jetzt leben wir gerade in Deutschland in einer Zeit, in der es immer mehr Ängste gibt gegenüber anderen, gegenüber Fremden, dem Fremden, den Fremden. Heimat wird immer mehr etwas offener, zumindest im Ballwerk, meiner Empfindung nach. Finden Sie, dass der Fußball da eine größere Rolle spielen sollte? Oder auch noch mehr für multikulturelles Leben einstehen sollte?
Fußball macht das schon. Man sieht heutzutage in der Bundesliga, wie viele ausländische Spieler spielen. Wenn ich 1994 gekommen bin, es waren vielleicht drei Brasiliener. Dann noch zwei aus Polen, aus Tschechien, Österreich und das war's. Heute sieht man, dass jeder Verein ein ausländischer Spieler hat. Es ist schön, diese Integration, diese Kultur einander auf der ganzen Welt zu zeigen. Das beste Image aus Deutschland hat Deutschland im WM 2014 in Brasilien gelassen. Zum Krönung sind sie auch Weltmeister geworden, weil sie es verdient haben. Deutschland hatte eine halbe Quartier ganz oben im Norden Brasilien, wo es am ist, in Salvador, Bahia. Und da hat die brasilianische Fernsehen jeden Tag Bericht live aus einem deutschen Fußballcamp gezeigt, die Spieler mit den einheimischen Leuten am Strand entlang, dass Schweinsteiger ihnen das Trikot gegeben haben, Manuel Neuer das Lied von einem Verein, der gesungen hat oder versucht zu singen. Und das war sehr schön. Weil da hat die Deutsche gezeigt, nicht was die Brasilien denkt, dass die Deutsche nur kalt sind. Also die sind Menschen, die können auch lachen, die können weinen, die sind so wie wir. Und das war sehr, sehr gut und sehr positiv.
Abschließende Frage, was ist denn für Sie Heimat? Wie definiert sich das jetzt für jemanden wie Sie, der ja an ganz vielen Orten sich heimisch fühlt?
Also gestern habe ich das noch gelesen, so ein Schild in der Nähe von Neue Schweinsteinschloss. Heimat ist, wo man sich wohlfühlt. Also ich bin hier in München, budenwohl, ich bin zu Hause, fühle mich wohl. Wenn meine Familie noch dabei ist, ist es noch schöner. Es ist noch schöner, ja.
Kennen Sie das? Das ist eine Frage, die muss man noch hinterher schieben. Habe ich an mir erlebt, was für ein Mensch man wirklich ist, sieht man erst, wenn man Kinder hat und die dann erzielt. Ich sage immer wieder Dinge zu meinen Zwillingen, wo ich mir denke, oh, das hat sich jetzt angehört, wie meine Mutter oder wie mein Vater, oder das war jetzt aber ganz schön spießig. Haben Sie schon manche Sachen zu Ihren Kindern gesagt, wo Sie sich dachten, das war jetzt aber ganz schön deutsch?
Ja, das passiert immer. Also, Gott sei Dank wissen die das und die verstehen auch sehr gut Deutsch. Weil ab und zu kommt schon ein oder andere Wort auf Deutsch zu meinen Kindern. Und ich gucke schon an, jetzt ist sehr ernst geworden der Papa.
Und so vom Erziehungsstil her, haben Sie irgendwelche Prinzipien, wo Sie sagen würden, also wenn mir diese ganzen kulturellen Eindrücke aus Deutschland, der Schweiz und Italien fehlen würden, würde ich wahrscheinlich meine Kinder anders erziehen?
Also, ich versuche meine Kinder so zu erziehen, zu zeigen, wie ich geworden bin. Wie ich von nichts was erreicht habe. Aber nicht deswegen bin ich hochnäsig geworden. Und das brauche ich auch nicht, ich hasse das. Und das habe ich meinen Kindern beigebracht. Das soll alle Menschen respektieren, egal was die für Hautfarbe haben oder Geld und Portmone haben. Alle sind gleich und man muss die anderen respektieren. Und, Gott sei Dank, die machen das auch so.
Sehr gut. Giovane Elber, vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Das war unser Kurzpass mit Giovane Elber. Vielen herzlichen Dank an den FC Bayern, der das möglich gemacht hat, dass wir Giovane Elber in seiner Rolle als Markenbotschafter treffen durften. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wenn ja, dann folgt uns auf Facebook, folgt uns auf Twitter, folgt uns auf YouTube und hinterlasst uns gerne positive Bewertungen bei iTunes. Da freuen wir uns immer darüber. Und wenn ihr zu Supportern werdet, ja, dann liegen wir euch quasi zu Füßen. Alle Informationen dazu gibt es unter rasenfunk.de unterstützen. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und ich würde mich sehr freuen, eure Ohren auch noch mal in einer der kommenden Ausgaben des Rasenfunk geliehen zu bekommen. Bis dahin, habt eine gute Zeit, macht's gut, ciao! Das war die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.